what up reject nation we gonna watch
ourselves the first episode of moon
night today of course joined by our
great friend koi john drow here our
comic book expert easily knows moon
knight slightly better than john reading
that's right he's he's been reading
he's an expert now
hey of course full length watch long as
we stick it with the timecode or over at
our patreon page become a superject
today by checking all the content we got
to offer over there thank you for the
support and if you can't join our
patreon page the least you can do is
leave a like
subscribe and click the notification
bell also get notified when our reaction
for the next episode of moon knight is
up lastly them handsome devils over at
prepper you keep the light on for me and
the moon of
[Music]
it's gotta be arthur harrow right sure
looks like ethan hawk
oh yeah oh god oof
it's a disney show get that
self-flagellation boy
oh boy that's how you open a moon night
[Music]
yes sir every kid on their disney plus
app has got a crazy idea now crazy ideas
ruining the children oh man what a great
intro
[Music]
great mirroring and then literally
mirroring that's great they believed you
needed your heart to be judged in the
underworld and only the worthiest would
be allowed to pass through the field to
read and did it suck for you getting
rejected from the field of reads what if
that makes sense because i'm not dead oh
my god some corner foreshadowing is
happy
oh that accent's gonna be a thing
they're like figs and dates and
fight [ __ ] my next horse here but
seven
tomorrow
best steak in town
oh yeah yeah right so sorry
are you asking me out
you're funny it's gonna be an awkward
ass date dad
rascal i didn't know you're taking a
crack she's dating mark the banners and
the posters of the aniad so what the any
ad
you know like the super group of
egyptian gods you know you've got shoes
stop please if this is some weird
audition to tour guide here the answer
is still no i know what
that's actually crashing to here oh
buddy i swear i'll shove you in a
sarcophagus you can tell the bloody
pharaoh in there what's wrong with him
and oh foreshadowing
you shanna you're from london did you
take a picture of us yeah sure thank you
yeah we're going on a date i didn't even
ask her i don't know how it happened you
think he's friends with all the
personalities oh that'd be fun i am
going to have a girlfriend
at some point obviously can't have ankle
restraints on my bed can i not you never
know find yourself someone kinky some
people are into that sort of thing
stephen
hello
and welcome to staying awake
let's start with trying to solve a
puzzle
reading can keep your mind alert and
focused
imagine being in the story you're
reading this is a square game soundtrack
sounds a little like yeah solving
puzzles is a great way to keep your mind
awake
between god and man
oh
[Music]
surrender the body to mark of course
friend of the body what body ah the
idiot's in control
yes
[Music]
that's good though keep zig zagging
that's smart
[Music]
i judge you in amit's name with but a
fraction of her power
this is the face of a good man
there's one out there found them who
would like to go next
please hello
i must know
oh
i've been good my entire life i believe
you but the scales see everything
perhaps it's something that lies ahead
oh no i wish you could live to see the
world we make lies ahead she's like 90.
[Music]
fingers froze
oh that's so good me every time i handle
them
being taunted oh that's so good
i don't know what's happening there we
go just take a picture
oh god
[Laughter]
oh dude
this is so good
[Applause]
windy road reflective of his state
understand what's is
oh
no
nice
wow
final destination
[Music]
oh my god
he just throw the gun
down he must be parasite
ouch
it was all just a dream guys that's it
show's over we'll put a bunch of
[ __ ] just go back to the gift shop
how many footsteps are going to be
around the sand how are we doing ghost
sheep all right i wonder what fishes
dream about
oh my god they put in the fish stick
oh this finn's back what fish
oh the fish yesterday that fish had one
fin yeah he would like that when i
bought him today what do you see i see
two fins yeah sorry
is that clock right no that's impossible
i just woke up you're mad the fish is
wrong the time is wrong you're not quite
right
fish is going on a date what the fish
bring them with you you wanted to show
them the world fin man
oh that imagery is going to be fun later
symbolism
[Music]
ah symbolism definitely because of all
the different slabs and the red
each pane of glass represents pain
anything with multiple dividing lines is
awesome
i think friday still comes after
thursday doesn't it
it doesn't change the fact that today is
sunday which means lose my number
oh
oh i still got to see our work
buddy i'll have the best bit of the uh
that's the bit that i want
oh
man
[Music]
oh it's good to have oscar isaac at the
mcu that's exactly what i was thinking
like i think how lucky are we here
it's just one character or something
anyway i'll tell you more about it
tomorrow love you
later gators
that's a new quote moon knight t-shirts
with the loki gator it's an easter egg
reference
that shot was a metaphor for loneliness
disk disk
[Music]
good old razer phone
been texting and calling you for a month
i just found this phone in my flat and
i'm just trying to figure out who's it
is what is with this accent who do you
think i am
what do you mean who what's wrong with
you mark
why did you call me mark
no no no no no come on come on
laila
oh yeah
thank you
kill her
don't trust her are we back on the fifth
floor yes the thief my friend claire
lives here she's expecting me
what's going on
it's like a j horror movie oh good call
yeah
[Music]
oh no
see you really do work here oh
i'd assumed steven grant was an alias
imagine my surprise to find you here
excuse me ronnie this man right here
he's been following me no i don't know
please
they own everything ronnie the country
the scarab doesn't belong to me it
belongs to her
do you know ahmed she knows what we've
done or what we will do great okay well
books must have left that part out
oh my god all the patrons she would have
prevented hitler and the destruction he
wrote near the armenian genocide pol pot
but she was betrayed by even her own
avatar avatars
blue people
beat us to the joke stephen
[Laughter]
do you want to know the truth
there are things to go bump in the night
this chaos in you
[Music]
[Laughter]
and we gotta eat that hawk in here they
did like this is so good yeah it's
really good i hear you can you hear me
are you about to get us an anubis
[Music]
terrible god
wow
i think it's terrifying you need to give
me control you understand control of
what you're talking about
that thing's about to break through the
door we're out of time
it's like a universal studio's ride
great choreography
you're not gonna die
let me save us
oh it just
chills just everywhere so many moments
moon knight theme song yes look at them
you're stuck in here with me
[Music]
beautiful beautiful work hell yeah
wow
step out of the way hawkeye episode one
we got a new favorite
goddamn
i'm so glad they saved like i never knew
oscar isaac's voice like i'm so glad
they saved mark from all of the
marketing yeah yeah yeah because it felt
exciting to hear just oscar isaac
yeah
he's so good at that
like i dawned on me like in the middle
of like i i don't see an accent at all
like it's that thing where you just
think that's his voice you would assume
that if this is the first time you're
seeing oscar isaac i would go oh the
american accent's the voice he's putting
on yeah yeah and the duality between
that like nasally it sounds you know
insecure versus his commanding isaac
voice as well as the accent yeah
you know that's an easter egg
i am just a nazi direction well he's
just trying like like three and a half
oh my god ex
it did leave me with a question though
did he ask that girl out with an
american accent and then she was like
and then she was just like whatever
british now he's got he's got jokes i i
assume everyone thinks he's you know f
murray abraham
nice
so it was not sean connery from beyond
no no i'm trying to bring him back
yeah let's get all those ai voices that
always go god that is a beautiful
closing credits
what a stunning show visually like
they're really great at expressive
camera work even express yourself
just express yourself don't hurt anybody
i like
knew i'd like the show and i didn't know
how hard it would go like you know
everyone's been concerned about disney
to the point where i was like starting
to believe them and that was
really violent oh i signed my age
restriction you know pin and everything
that give me business now
here it is i mean that that's moon
knight like they they accomplish the
really
pondersome tone when he's piecing
together like the the existential dread
but they also the cinematography reads
like the comics which have this really
uh i mean have you read the greg
smallwood illustrated stuff yet is that
the six issue one yeah no i i i i'm
gonna get that okay so the visuals there
remind me so much mdm right now yeah the
smallwood visuals there you'll see all
right
what are you thinking
no i don't even talk there
i'm good with just sitting and taking it
in just absorbing i feel like i need to
be a
goddamn critic
to watch us watch
us
i'm trying to take in the credits here
we are that's what i really came to the
show for
just see all the jobs they created
that's
beautiful work you guys was talking i
missed a casting associate in the uk
thanks [ __ ]
the transport coordinator though
transport is important there should be
an oscar for best transpo
uh easter egg i did notice that wasn't
oh credits okay
[Music]
egg cupcake truck it was a lack of
easter egg because everybody's like it's
fondue i don't think it's
on the cupcakes i don't know who
actually believed that a lot of people
but you guys are crazy
this is actually the most separated from
the mcu out of them all that's why i
don't like i didn't notice a lot of
strikes personally i didn't feel and i'm
i'm glad because the eternal scenes
where they were like shoehorning in
marvel felt off to the tone of the film
or is this actually
at the very end i like the opinion
of non-praise about the eternals there
is the occasional flaw what in a very
good fight
occasion we'll fly you like everything
that's not true everything
and i cut that out of the actual video
and now it's on the wreck
now you
know a throwback to a cut joke and now
it's real let's talk about it let's talk
about it all right
you know let's do this differently okay
go our new comic book aficionado yes the
one everybody wants to hear from no i
love this i thought this was really
really terrific and yeah i mean you know
from my
extensive knowledge now of the comics i
mean this does feel very spiritually
sound i mean yeah steven has been a bit
re-contextualized but i like the choice
to do that i think he's a really
effective yeah i mean he's not the
billionaire guy you know the
philanthropist playboy or whatever i
like the choice to really bring us into
his world as a character who is a bit
more nebushy and down on his luck and i
love the disorientation they throw you
for with all these things that are
happening in an episode like this they
have to be economical with that time and
i thought the way that they managed to
hop to so many different things
utilizing that lapse in consciousness
was really smart all the way through
their camera work was so complementary
and so expressive to the point where
like all of these are incredibly finely
crafted but this was a show this episode
alone was an episode where i was like no
shot is wasted here everything feels
like it has a lot of thought put into it
oscar isaac it's it's hard to say enough
things about him and even though we've
only had a few glimpses at uh arthur
harrow ethan hawke i i love his presence
as well and i love that even though he
does have a sinister quality about him
there's something that isn't
very uh
your boy
even though there is a sinister quality
about him something about him that
doesn't seem like you know he's a
mustache twirler you know like i like
his dedication his devotion to you know
this
you know almost profit-like role that he
is playing you know in conjunction with
the gods and i just can't wait to see
more yeah
[Music]
i loved it uh
i love that there was a moment where we
all went like oscar isaac there was one
like acting choice after another that
was so interesting so captivating and
it's really hard because of the big
change they did with steven uh i think
it's smart to have the batman
similarities separate because there's
enough people talking about how he's
marvel's batman so you get rid of the
playboy first uh so i love that the
duality between mark and steven is that
direction about weakness and strength
and i really enjoyed the disorientation
we as an audience experienced having
only steven's perspective we only got to
experience that and then his
disorientation of losing time and losing
cognizance so it it would be
his perspective what i'm curious is is
if we'll get an episode where it's like
we're with mark the whole time or if
we're in an episode where we like meet
the third identity and we we lose time
or if they played that just for the
pilot and now we're gonna or i don't
know if they're considered pilots if you
get a season order but you know what i
mean if we're gonna play with uh
different personalities or now that
we've already dealt with these two if
it'll be more streamlined more more
narrative structure uh that being said i
loved ethan hawk so much i think he's so
talented but seeing him in this this
darkness i like that it mirrored the
footsteps like we we got that opening
that was that was you know his his
punishing self flagulation but we also
then saw uh the the walk of moon knight
i do think we're gonna see a lot more
similarities in this hero villain
pairing as we meet mark i think we're
going to see how similar they are and i
really liked that it opened with the
villain in this case and then followed
through
yeah you know the filmmakers they did
say or one of the creators said that
this is like fight club meets indiana
jones i couldn't agree more like already
from the first episode i could just
imagine how much more archaeological
swashbuckling this is all gonna feel
like this didn't feel like r-rated to me
or any stretch it doesn't feel like it's
our i don't know it's just the first
episode but the first episode was more
like that dark pg-13 supernatural horror
flare that i really love and especially
like staying within the museum it is
like indiana jones national treasure but
like better than national treasure
one of those flares that i really liked
a lot locking it into solely steven's
perspective a gives you a character to
really endear yourself to you know it's
like there's aphemisms about them that
kind of remind you of a bit like uh how
you get kind of endeared like toby
maguire the first spider-man movie like
everyone just seems to pick on this guy
when he's when he's just a such a softy
you know pathetic
even chase is a bust like peter a little
pathetic yeah even chase is a bus like
peter at the very top of it locking it
into his perspective allows you to do
some very interesting camera choices and
editing choices that can be kind of
shocking and cool and also that much
more immersive and i thought that was
one of the most unique things about what
they did here was actually having the
delays those shifts those visual motifs
without showing you the events when
they're without showing you what mark
specter is doing when he's taking over
makes it more immersive to not actually
see it which is so unique like you don't
get usually to make an immersive you've
got to really envelop yourself in the
actual thing that's happening in the
present moment but throwing you into
what he's going through really puts you
there doesn't make me curious like what
the overall character arc will be for
him because obviously they've
established like i've had that same
thought too i've expressed that quite a
few times the three main person is like
jake stephen and mark in the comments i
met jake we haven't met jake we don't
even know if he exists yet uh within
this world or if it will be introduced
it'll be the post credit scene
very yeah
luckily
get in my cat
weird thing
this is his arc the way how the people
were like bruce wayne in the billionaire
playboy in batman this is it this is ark
into becoming a billionaire playboy the
first my way
that's where the money is well i was
wondering like what the what the
character arc will ultimately be will it
be one of those things where because it
seems like we're going to have some of
that almost venom and eddy thing where
he you know he's it's interacting with
kanchu within his head can we talk about
a great country looks conscious
conscious looks great that bus scene i
think might be my favorite when he's
just standing there for a few frames and
then disappears just the scope of them
the size the ethereal like up close we'd
seen a couple shots but the the scope of
what they were able to do and making him
feel tangible but intangible at the same
time absolutely i think what they did
with his music with the music around
them too and usually around this whole
show like they had some needle drops but
then they also had some just original
score that had that like operatic
egyptian flair to it and sometimes was
very pulsating the scene work between
arthur harrow and stephen grant is is
phenomenal what excites me most is
because when you get two actors like
that they understand the importance of
dynamics and the relationship so when we
have mark specter interacting with
arthur harrow it's gonna be like a
completely different scene it's gonna be
like two different actors are
interacting with each other you know and
you have that calvin actor for that
reason cause apparently you know they're
friends and that's how ethan hawk got
brought on so i love the idea that
they're actually going like no no we
want to have this fight this actor fight
like we want to have this ted attack
speaking to what you're saying about the
arc i really think it's going to be
interesting to see if the show lands
with him being able to control his
identities more and be and being able to
decide which one is serving the best
purpose because in the comics sometimes
that's the case not always but i do
think it's gonna be interesting if mark
takes over to a level that we see you
know the badass kind of steering more
it's gonna be like that scene in the two
towers when gollum is like talking with
himself yeah go away
and never return
go i never return
later yeah that action scene was really
well shot i think this just strikes a
really cool mood and a really good
mystery but also keeping it refreshing
and what makes oscar isaac's performance
i think so strong just how much this all
weighs on him like starting it off where
he just has no you guys are using the
word disorientation a lot so i'll use it
you know everyone used to work dance for
eternals yeah so that's the news
orientation disorientation disney plus
disorientation
oscar isaac's performance is just how
much that weighs on that's why that
restaurant scene was so powerful
it wasn't just that like oh my god he's
crying whoa good acting you know which
is the mark of any good actor he cries
that's all you got good acting all right
that's all you need
a lot of anger and a lot of crying good
acting it's the way he interacted like
he's not receiving at all what the
waiter is telling him like he's vegan
they established that he's giving in to
the meat just like succumbing to it
something he's had to like kind of
discipline himself i imagine to resist
that like something's like little as
that some sort of nuance but to make
that choice but clearly he likes meat
and then he has to he's going to get
something that has had to disappoint
himself to go against because he's just
falling apart internally but he's just
asking all these questions just like
it'd be so polite so affable yeah yeah
whatever yeah okay uh-huh that's good
but you can see him just breaking down
while trying to put on a face
ah powerful stuff so yeah i think oscar
isaac's performance here is just so
strong like i care so much i care so
much about stephen grant this is the
first marvel show that they introduced a
character right like as your protagonist
that bishop was the closest but that was
still like the jumping off point was we
got clint barton i think it's the clock
this is all brand new people like
everyone here and that's why i was
saying i'm glad there's not a lot of
easter eggs not a lot of references a
lot of i like that we get to live in the
supernatural by itself for a second i'm
not looking for stuff maybe i shouldn't
be but i'm enjoying like just the
experience of it and also i keep
bringing them up but greg smallwood's uh
his art style has this really beautiful
kind of like pencil shading aesthetic to
the underneath and i'm loving how
they're using shading i'm loving how
they're using like darkness versus light
i love the little detail of having a
white hood but like the use of lighting
is playing into how i visually see the
comic books there's always this very
heavy inked book and it makes it
obviously the supernatural tone but it
also feels like more of a translation of
the comic to the screen than some of the
other shows have for me personally like
sometimes the comic it feels like a
marvel show like they're going for a
marvel color palette this doesn't feel
like a marvel color palette it feels
like the comic inks are on screen yeah
yeah yeah it's got really expressive
light and i love that you name check
j-horror because it definitely has a
certain element of that which is also
very inky in a very sort of depth of the
shadows kind of genre and two we talked
about in one of the trailer reactions
about how you know they're talking about
this is going to be a level up in terms
of how harsh you know a marvel disney
flush show can get and i've never been
one to think that they'll go daredevil
netflix level but
i do appreciate that like in that scene
where he kills those people there is
blood and the blood on his hand is very
striking and it made me go we don't
really often see
blood of consequence in these things and
even that was something that was like
really striking just from a color and
just from a palette sort of standpoint
well i think the most survey these
thoughts at the opening scene stepping
into a sandal full of glasses that was
so cool
and that's such a bold way to open any
show much less a disney show like any
show opening that way it's like what am
i watching what am i investing in i can
just imagine a whole family getting
around got the new marvel show river
hawkeye oh my gosh
remember that christmas show we just
watched man what is the life let's put
on moon night now it's spring
i also i think it was really smart to
keep all of the marketing largely in the
first episode like most of the stuff we
saw in the trailers was it here i know
i've picked the whole series together oh
okay i'm sorry yeah i know what's going
on yeah here we go that's why you know
about the cabbie at the end it's all
about the fish right to the podium
damn it these fish has all the ends
underneath all along
gus the fish is gus the fish a future
head avenger that's the question
definitely definitely that's the big
easter guys the easter egg starts the
pet events got you just all four minutes
you thought they were going young
avengers no no it's a dog
alligator from loki loki gator perfect
yeah we got i mean that's five that's an
avengers team yeah do it cut the check i
stopped listening i know you guys felt
that listen moon night's done
everyone's done today listen uh follow
koi over on his um
[ __ ] you forgot to tell me i got a
youtube and tick tock oh at the top
top of the show i'll just put a little
logo on a [ __ ] [ __ ] i'm the worst
it's my fault
could you just yeah
give me one assignment it just reminds
me of how you're talking about i thought
my assignment was to know moonlight
the show doesn't even really need you to
know moonlight that's nice though right
now
are unnecessary how approachable the
show is considering how dense to use
your word moon oh yeah disorienting
listen uh i can follow us on patreon
thanks john for um
doing it all man he's in the moonlight
experience the moon not an expert
there's probably a split personality of
john that just knows everything yeah
he's never here when i freaking beat him
if i i would be always in steven graham
right i would be so upset to find out
the complete shadow relief of all the
things i struggle with that's just like
a guy jolly reading like your cut scene
is this guy like oh that's nice gone
completely useless one thing before we
go arthur harrow i like the way they
have drawn him as this prophet for
people this uh savior it's such a unique
way of cleansing the world of talking
about bringing heaven to earth
of all right let the god judge whether
or not you're a good person or not okay
you're bad we're wiping you off
that is fascinating it's a it's a fresh
spin on the environmentalist villain
that we see all the time you know
yeah and left that notes planned like
heaven's gatey sort of cultism too yeah
it's a lot of stuff it's more
individualized it's a much more like
personal way to kill somebody like
you're you're seeing it's almost like
the penance there with ghost tracker was
it like a nazi in the comics or
something yeah i mean definitely like
that but with a hydra it doesn't really
work as well but yeah like definitely in
that tonality
moon night
pick up a comic today kids yeah and step
on some glass while you're at it
there's a secret shelf kelly vereer i
couldn't think of anything then thank
you for being here guess who is josh
faroo
bet you never heard of this one randy
boom
film star damian chappa mendoza mr jimmy
burns king alan ling
jacob i want to climb your ladder
height ted theodore logan burton guster
ericans
39 dudes tootsie fruitsy cousy cousy
justin will smith
uncle phil eider carlton there's a bear
in the garage
nick x is not a fresh prince character
longshlong juan longoria gail fergie
ferguson jaren
fergie wanner cliff the big red
rodriguez crispy thrust in the busting
if i were alex biwer i'd learn how to
say your name right master t the o g
pseudonymous entity the o o g
olivia the wise guy and the funk
nuff said lorenzo baxter
i tried doing a round burger dinner
giftedly differently same
levitt odell good he smells ralph lauren
american eagle
polo has a horse insignia
simply pimply faded pimples pimps anyway
guys
thank you so much for pledging to our
patreon your support has gotten us
through
the best of times things were already
good and you just made it even better
so thank you
seriously
tell the best receive it receive the
gratitude
thank you say thank you
when i say thank you you say no thank
you
you're welcome
[Music]